am freitag besucht verteidigungsminister
im kerker tanna der angelobung der re
kunden des abwehrzentrums im
niederösterreichischen bisamberg
[Musik]
sie haben sie sich tatsächlich für einen
verband entschieden der ganz besonders
ist nicht nur im österreichischen
bundesheer sondern weit darüber hinaus
und der gerade jetzt zeigt wie wichtig
dieses fachgebiet zur bewältigung der
szenarien ist das zeigt uns nicht nur
der krieg in der ukraine sondern das
muss wir schon in zusammenhang mit der
bewältigung der pandemie erleben es ist
die wertschätzung die große
wertschätzung
für ihren dienst denn sie in den
kommenden monaten leisten werden sie
werden ein versprechen abgeben ein
persönliches versprechen auf die
republik österreich
kameraden spricht mir nach ich glaube
mein vaterland
die republik österreich
und sein volk zu schützen und
blickte waffe zu verteidigen
ich glaube
den gesetzen und den gesetzmäßigen
behörden
treue und gehorsam zu leisten
eine beziehung meiner vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen und
mit all meinen kräften
der republik österreich und
dem österreichischen volk
zu dienen
[Applaus]